you want to be on tv [ __ ] kill
somebody don't don't go to acting class
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
spring is in the air and everything is
turning green but you might want to so
smoking green should be just as pleasant
and as refreshing as taking a dip in the
pool
or teabagging someone for the smoothest
coolest and biggest hits you got to try
freeze pipe you know and this is true
freeze pipe
you know it really is kind of a
revolutionary way to smoke so they make
a unique line of freezable pipes uh
bubblers bongs and more so so
when you when you smoke a normal thing
sometimes people cough because
it gets you but if you use freeze pipe
it's almost like uh
um
eating like a thin mint
if you're eating choncho and then you
put a thin mint and you went
the panocha would taste like mint
scientifically engineered to cool smoke
by over 300 degrees
uh you can expect a smoother and bigger
hit
without the intense coughing
or throat burn i put it on my cool and
[Laughter]
coughed and the air came in remember how
the girl used to be able to do ping pong
balls in vietnam
uh
that probably not going to make it to
the ad all right so go ahead
use code omghi for 10
that's
thefreezepipe.com and code omghi for 10
off if you smoke marijuana
um
what would you say like if you were a
tennis player you'd want to get the best
tennis racket right yeah you want to get
a good record if you smoke marijuana
how do i make it sound uncool marijuana
all right
if you if you smoke if you are a smoker
of cannabis
invest in a freeze pipe and i guarantee
you the way that you you have
cannabis will never be the same if you
bought a tv you'd want to buy one with a
picture of a picture with a plasma the
the most the best screen
if you're into this
into the cannabis which a lot everybody
is almost now
invest in a freeze pipe and you will not
i'm telling you right now you won't
regret it
and it wouldn't be the same
and he says okay you probably don't
remember what you that's it exactly and
i said okay same things last year
so i told the wife
i said they want you back i said yes
they do
what are you going to talk on this time
he said the same thing i did last year
so i don't know
i don't remember
so saturday night i went out there
drinking some wine
with some people they said what are you
gonna talk about tomorrow
and i said oh no i'll find out when i
get up on stage
so i got up on stage and
it was like a television show george
i've never been
they had
they had production people this is it's
sponsored by oxygen tv
so they had a big [ __ ] [ __ ]
timer 45 minutes top 45 migrate clocking
you down
the
stage was set with arrows and lines
how far i could wander or not wander
and you have a uh uh
handheld or do they put it to your
leveler just one of those up there
and that's lav
they have a different room set up for
that they have a sound people
go to this room they put on they put
makeup and all this [ __ ]
and i went out there and uh oh good to
see you good to see you guys it really
is good to see you
and uh
we talked
i went up there and start talking we
kissed we [ __ ]
and the next thing i know 45 minutes was
up and i got a stanley know when i'm
done and so
and these people you you thought i was
george lopez the way they were
uh i told you i never get those no
i
i had people coming up to me
i i told the old lady when i got back
that there were at least a thousand
people come up
during the three days that i was there
taking pictures signing wanted
autographs these are people that follow
that true crime stuff yeah and i said i
annoyed and they're not a bunch of
they're not a bunch of wackos did you
ask what were they able to ask questions
or yeah yeah they had a couple of
sessions the first thing ah
live podcast hey
i got their first day they'd asked me in
advance would you be part of a live live
podcast
sure i'm a pro so i went up there to do
this live podcast on my [ __ ] pro and
these guys they had uh bourbon
oh and they were up there drinking
bourbon if they wanted bourbon they had
wine for me if i wanted wine
so i said i'm with you this is your pot
he has like burgers uh whiskey yeah his
show is called whiskey ginger so they
have whiskey all over the place yeah so
it was it was good
and so you went on the podcast yeah and
the host there had the host had
everything and all kinds of people out
there
and they were live with an audience yeah
live with an audience and they start
screaming is inside this great big hall
this is just one section of all they had
set up is that a convention center right
there by the west gate it's in the paris
hotel oh
and uh
so went up there they said what do you
think and i just looked down i said this
is insanity you know they were screaming
they were did this i'm not using this
this kind of stuff but let's do what we
got to do
and so the podcast went well
uh i did that i did live zoom for
somebody
i had a [ __ ] all around huh yeah
one of these one of these groups of
people i think they're paying like for
vip tickets i want to say it's like 1500
bucks
and i'm saying you get to go to every
event you get to go to any event you
want to and that includes a room a
little smaller than this
you sign up you get 10 minutes with
guilt korean private no [ __ ] yeah
it doesn't come cheap
no so well they
whoever you want to go see whoever you
want to spend time with
it's there you do an autograph signing
section you do photograph section
they had [ __ ] all lined up okay so when
you if you signed autographs did they
pay
was that did they pay you one did you
get paid yeah i got paid they pay you
one time for everything yeah or if you
signed autographs you got paid per
autograph no they they you sign up one
thing for for everything
and they ask you will you give your time
to do this will you do this what you do
i realize they're not
you know it not naive somebody's making
bank over there yeah i know they're
making bank who would that be the guy
that puts it no somebody has the idea
right yeah somebody has the idea let's
do crime con
then you hire
maybe a company
that puts it all together yes produces
it so yeah and then
oxygen and then oxygen channel which
used to be the lady channel wasn't it
now it's all
yeah
you want to be on tv [ __ ] kill
somebody don't don't go to acting class
so they they had
i'm doing this with them
but i'm sitting there thinking because
i've never forgotten where i came from
and i could see these people i have by
the way
you've forgotten where you came from
yeah [ __ ] yeah
i'll ever be remembered for that so so
okay sidetracked so
when you when you're having trouble in a
relationship
the therapist will say why don't you go
why don't we go back and do an exercise
like you set up a date night now every
night now you have to ask her out like
if you've never met
hi
how's the how's it going would you like
to have dinner on saturday
um
sure um and you're driving separate cars
oh my god to make it all look
authentic
right when i did that
i didn't show up i said i've made the
first mistake i'm not going back in
there again what's the [ __ ] letter no
but you know guys have to go and then
sweet talk you i wouldn't your wife i
wouldn't do that and then and then you
say hey would you like to go back to my
place
and the [ __ ] [ __ ] probably says yeah
and there you go right there
and there's nothing like the first time
the idea is like recreate the magic you
have to recreate your relationship
so so all right so so because uh there's
therapy cons too where let's say those
guys like like um
uh tony robbins
or
people that go and have 5 000 people and
then you go
and they try to fix you
amongst 5 000 people
you know what they're doing so then so
then you go to this thing
it's not just one day right it's
probably the whole week no i started
with a pot live podcast fridays friday
saturday sunday i spoke uh
sunday morning did my last thing with
them uh
midday sunday where i gave my private
time to these people
and then that was it then i'm done no no
no matter of fact sunday night i had
they asked me they had a
mob museum
in las vegas oh cool
i've never been there i don't give two
shits about a mob museum
but they asked me in advance would you
show up that way they could publicize
gil carrillo is going to be at the mom
museum i would care about the mob museum
myself
you have bugsy seagulls eye
they do
no
no i didn't get his eyeshadow and then
they had the closing
you know whatever you call after you
shoot a movie when they have drinks
together everybody
a wrap party yeah they had the wrap
party sunday night and then that that
was it
but
it was just long days did you think you
got underpaid it's to me it sounds like
you got underpaid yeah i did yeah yeah i
i know i did uh they asked i went and i
told uh
kevin belf
the guy that's running everything i said
hey listen
you're gonna have to cut up with some
bucks you know last time
you asked me to do this i was last
minute add-on and it cost me 500 out of
my pocket by time i got done
we didn't talk about ground
transportation we didn't talk about per
diem food and stuff like that oh yeah so
yes i know somebody's making a nickel as
well we don't have a buy so i don't care
about your budget somebody's making a
nickel i'm gonna make a nickel
and i'm not
asking for the gold i'm not asking for
the vault to open up for me i'm just
saying i'm not gonna put any money out
of my pocket
and so we got that we got that
straightened out
but i told him last night i was there i
said some of these people that go there
people like you know dr phil was there
phil hansen you know to catch a predator
uh matt murphy from i i love matt murphy
you know matt murphy was from
orange county he's the one that did the
uh
the dating gate uh prosecuted dating
cape murder
uh uh rodney caller rodney alcala he did
rodney
just a straight up guy okay so the
dating game murderer there's a guy named
rodney akala just passed away
he was a good looking guy yeah went on
went on the dating game one
he was already
he was already a killer when he went on
the dating game told you back then what
kind of betting they did
so they were going they were gonna want
a trip to go to
somewhere and the girl got creeped out
by him and called the dating game and
said i don't think i want to go on a
date with this guy this guy's creepy
and probably saved her own life exactly
i'm pretty sure that guys exactly
and matt murphy who was with the orange
county d.a he does a lot of date line
and 48 hours kind of stuff now
as an expert matt murphy
yeah i think that was matt murphy i
think that was his last name he's not no
okay and and he just
when i got there and after seeing the
news there
that was the highlight of my my whole
weekend i got to meet him because i
thought i respect him is he the older
guy that goes through
he's not an older guy he's not that old
he's got gray hair but i mean he looks
good doesn't look that old
and
he just he does it it's my highlight and
i find out later he he told the crowd i
spoke after i was done he went up to
speak later on he told people in that
in his group that the highlight of his
whole weekend was being able to hook up
with me
and so he says hey maybe we can hook up
with
uh something in the future maybe we can
do something together
okay
uh the guy that catches the [ __ ]
supremes over here we're ready to go
[ __ ] solo here diana ross
and let it be known to one and all
within the listening purview of this
this podcast
i was feeling lonely man i was out there
we had i haven't seen you in a few weeks
i haven't seen sam here uh and and i
just and maybe this is it maybe they're
telling me goodbye don't bother me no
we haven't been done so you know i've
been away and and i don't i don't call
you asking what you're doing because
you're saying you're not my wife i'm not
going
so no no no no no uh
but it was it fun to get i've been on
another podcast was it fun to be
in that
in that um
atmosphere
yeah it was it was i thoroughly enjoyed
it
uh
what do you think what do you think made
crime
what do you think maine crimes so
popular everything is about crime
everything is about crime everything is
about crime
i just watched you know it's
i hate to think it's all the things i
watch but it's a lot of it
what made crime popular
you could answer that one yourself
crime
brought me to you yes and and i don't
know what turns these people on you know
these people talk about it uh over there
like at crime con other people talk they
ask questions about
crime you know what was he really like
were you afraid when he went in the room
did he stink did he smell right was it
polite was your friend
uh those are questions other people
think about and i never
never once
thought about i never realized that
people cared that much and i thought if
people did care that much
before meeting you seriously
if i thought people that did care that
much
i thought these were just
not nuts people are [ __ ] loons yeah
they care about this and that yeah and
and so
after seeing all the people that were
there
very few of them i didn't meet anybody
that was way far out they were just
honest hard-working people to spend
their money because they do this they
they follow true crime what did critic
what did chris hansen talk about
uh i don't know i didn't go to these
lectures i don't i don't go listen to
any of their lectures
that's another thing have you seen this
guy that guy no i really don't care i
was in the business you know i listen to
somebody else talk about it
doesn't uh excite me
they did have and i stood away there was
uh
john bernay ramsey
oh she was there her father father her
father was that was that what that was
is that where you were at yeah
uh i saw him uh
i saw him uh a bit of his on the news
yeah um
that has to be
it has to be quite
different because his wife is gone
daughter's gone the daughter's gone
the
sun has sued
uh henry lee and cbs for the
dr henry lee yeah
i saw dr henry lee old friend good it
was great seeing him
man that's and who was he i'm less
familiar with this dr herron lee is best
noted for recently he's a blood spatter
next i would have had a big west so if i
was over there but he was uh
he tested he did this
the staircase
okay yeah yeah yeah but he did oj2
yeah
the guy yeah he he's and i've lectured
with him before the cop groups
at the same time we've had he came out
to one of my cases when i was in trial
on another murder case and it may have
even been richer than i was in trial for
a former partner of mine a female that i
broke in and homicide
we did a case
no she didn't all right
and
sorry
as they do though
they uh i saw a lady police officer with
big tethers i was like i'll i'll [ __ ]
run this light right
so did i i ran the light and she
wouldn't stop me
so
uh mr wang his daughter
uh
fiona
yeah mr wang and her husband his
son-in-law killed her
and we knew it
and mr wang had a lot of a lot of money
so we worked as far as we could and we
knew he did it but there wasn't enough
evidence to get a prosecution got away
with it yeah he did
yeah he did and so the wang family
paid they hired dr lee to come out here
from connecticut i think that's where
he's from
was it was was henry lee ever ever a uh
a coroner
no
so he just has his his degrees in his
forensics exactly everything he did was
all all there in forensics yeah he's a
blood spattering expert he does all that
stuff and so
he paid for him to come out i come into
my office one day big bay
bunch of tables in their desk and i walk
around
there's henry lee with my old part
female
talking to her and i said hey dr lee
what are you doing here
he says oh my god i just found out this
was your case i said yeah
he says oh mr wang hired me come out
here to look review this stuff
i read everything and when we get to on
our reports and by the way henry lee his
accent of henry lee is good considering
the way henry henry lee talks
he has such a
you know he's been in the united states
pretty much his whole life he's got such
a heavy accent and he's so good at what
he's talking about and he's so funny and
he's funny and you have to really
struggle to hear yeah you got to lean on
what he's saying that's why everybody
pays attention to him yeah his humor
gets his point across
he's great he really is and he just said
i told i didn't know when you get to our
reports that homicide guys do
the very end there's two names
one on top one on the bottom
and my name was right there along with
my partner's name that means it's our
case wow and he says i get all the way
to the very back i see it's your name
and i said yes
he said i just told mr wang if i'd have
known this how to save your money no
need for me to go out there
and he trusted me that much so it was
all good and he's and he can
he told mr wang i agree with everything
that they say in this report you know we
know who did it
but
tough to prove let me ask you a question
yes so so
when you retired
and and did frank salerno retire at the
same time that you did oh he retired
several years before he retired before
yes and then he became
a private investigator
pretty much yes
because i mean his credentials are
incredible oh they are he or he opened a
private investigator company yes okay
and then
when you were you forced to retire or
you retired i retired out of choice i i
had
the way it works before you used to have
to return mandatory at 60.
so you could sign away
if i want to wave it and keep going
i had signed papers i wanted to keep
going i wasn't ready to retire
i had just had my kidney taken out and i
just had my knee operated on
so now it's september
my i turned 60 in november wow
so i either have to they
go on with the process
and if the doctors say i'm not
physically capable yet
then that means i'm going to go without
a paycheck for a month or two
because my paper's in for each so
i just said no i'm 60 i'll just take it
take it the way i am
there's no need for 60. yeah
and uh did you want to go to work after
that
uh yeah i wanted to do something i i
didn't want to work
at the time i didn't want to work
i could have i could have stood on
as uh
working cold cases or homicide right and
i didn't want to do
uh
i did not like dealing with
snitches i didn't like dealing with
attorneys anymore with defense attorneys
yeah
and uh just the [ __ ] you got to put up
with
uh i was banging heads with the captain
that was there at the time
and so i just said hey i'm going out
at the top of my game why were you
banging heads with the captain
at the time did you think that did you
want to become a captain did you want i
did i did want to i didn't want to be a
captain
and
i thought i would be a captain
and
then
this guy got put in there because
you thought you did you think you got
slighted of being a captain not from not
from when he got put in or no no he he
got put in there
uh i understood why he got put in there
dave uh
he was good friends with mr tanaka and
at that time mr tanaka was getting all
of his
ducks in order because he was going to
be the heir apparent
so he's getting his people in order and
i understood and i was not bitter i was
not angry
at all
he had been lieutenant longer than i had
he didn't know the business like i did
because he did never work homicide and
he hadn't been there that long but
let him go
he was going to be put in there for a
while
just as an acting captain because our
captain went off injured
so now how did he get hurt it was
internal problem his problems yeah uh
that captain
made it official i'm not coming back
well this guy's been the acting captain
now for eight nine months
we're not gonna make captain yeah we're
not going to pull them out and then put
gil in there
so i i understood that
and
then we had our first staff meeting
not too long not too much after that
where they said
okay they want us to come up with a
budgetary
solution
no overtime they want to cut our
overtime budget to zero
here at homicide bureau oh boy and i
said that's an impossible act we can't
do it
and he said what do you mean we can't do
it i said
we are a reactionary force
we don't schedule our murders right so
somebody's been working here for five
hours today and then all of a sudden he
gets a murder
he goes out to three his eight hour day
is done so what are you going to do the
first time he tells a family hey sorry
my time's up i got to go
see you tomorrow
the first time somebody does that
they'll be rolled up the next day
and i just looked at him i said
you can't do it sorry
you know i know that can't be done yeah
so
i think we assume i think we assume that
the police the sheriffs the fire
department the paramedics that that that
that they're a 24-hour business
like but they but it is a business it is
it's not it's a public service
and i think the taxpayer paid for that
but
it's a company as well they run it they
got to run like a company exactly so i
would probably say that in every police
department everywhere it's understaffed
oh they are horse i'm sure i mean i
don't know why anybody would want to be
a police officer
um in these times
or even a teacher like teachers have
always gotten [ __ ]
with what they have to what they get
paid they should get paid double
because you know they're teaching kids
and you know kids don't have respect and
then it's a whole big thing but but
with the police
it's
there's not enough detectives and
there's too much crime and there's not
enough highway patrolmen and there's not
enough sheriffs and there's not enough
police department for every police
department everywhere and i think if the
police departments everywhere had to
give the actual numbers of how many
officers they need even to just get to
the to a level
i think people would go out there and
commit more crimes realizing that the
response time if you call 9-1-1 for
anything domestic they probably don't
show up
right i mean it's sad if you say there's
a guy with a knife in my i mean momo
called you bumble there was a guy there
was a guy in momo's neighborhood
in downey that was out there with the
[ __ ] samurai sword yes is this
recently overcrowded that he took his
samurai sword
[ __ ] stabbed his uh nativity scene
and his snowman he killed a snowman no
way and the guy was an all in black with
a backpack and he had a [ __ ] long ass
sword and he was going around
you know crazy taking swings
or any any other uh
a deer or whatever you had in your in
your front yard but the guy had
he was [ __ ] out of his mind one and
he had a [ __ ] saber and he was
swinging that thing i mean it's it's
[ __ ] dangerous man that shit's
[ __ ] dangerous it is no kid
i was doing the live uh at my house
live with channel
11.
they were doing we were doing a live
spot for my house
when a couple of guys were running from
the cops come try to go over my house no
[ __ ] yeah really siren's going on i
finally had to tell them uh excuse me
we have an emergency active crime scene
no [ __ ] yeah really and they got it on
my wife is saying
he's got a crowbar i said
i got something's going on why are you
making noise you know i'm on doing this
live yeah
and a couple of guys that burglarized
the house cops were on them
and they were running one guy had a
crowbar in his hand started to come over
my house come over to
my son was sitting outside my son first
thought it was
my his his nephew my grandson and his
buddy just horsing around
and he's sitting outside in the front of
my porch and they realize oh [ __ ] this
is a real dude
and he starts to get up well the guy
sees my son and he turns around and
starts running
and now my dog starts running after him
and i hear the family yeah
milo milo get back here and they're
screaming i said why not [ __ ] are you
screaming right now yeah and then come
to find out
it was two guys
trying to get away from a burglary so
it's in your neighborhood what did they
what did they rob
a sword it was a house uh probably about
two three blocks away
they went inside thought the house was
vacant there was a lady inside she
screamed picked up the phone they said
oh [ __ ] somebody's here and then they
took off running
so yeah and and so they came and they
were following and people were dying
9-1-1
and i got good pictures of them on my
cameras
gave me the cops didn't make a
difference cop says detective sheriff's
department worse for the department i
worked for said
you know i hate to tell you this but you
know we catch you guys
these guys will cop out as soon as they
cop out we'll give them a ticket and
they'll be right out the door i know
there's too much yeah no there's too
much so they don't they don't do
anything and what about if people have
like uh um
uh
like their own
neighborhood security what do they call
the security companies like
like private security yeah
those guys don't carry guns right no
they don't care are they trained in
anything other than just they can drive
i i don't know what they go through
because i know like a car they have all
they can do is yeah just look
intimidating
what what's going on over that's it
that's their
yeah [ __ ] you
all right don't do that don't call me
puto hey hey continue
so so they don't they don't have
anything they don't have any jerky they
have mace
and i had a job where all i only had was
mace i'd rather blow the [ __ ] guy
then shoot him with mace get him tired
he went that way
he's moving slow
but if you're in a job if you're a
[ __ ] adult male and
and the only thing you have to protect
yourself is mace
and there's like seven guys right there
just jack them all up
that's
and then you got their dna you can find
them
perfect
jack them off with one glove take a
glove and
put in a plastic bag i got them i can
tell you right now i can see a
recommendation for a one-hour training
class
you and you go faster at first
and then i don't know
and then you take the gloves you've had
they start knocking on people
is ron here
that that's him
but but
that's all they have is they don't have
a gun they're not trained they don't
know how to shoot they probably don't
there are some guards that are armed
security if they got license and stuff
like that if you have an iron on [ __ ]
badge i don't if you're a man and you
have an ir if you're a security agent
and your badge is ironed on nobody's
going to take you seriously the way
civil liability is today nobody's doing
anything everybody's afraid to do it
don't you see my bad it's ironed on
hey [ __ ] you there
yeah they don't do anything with them
come over here
you're already set up spread them you
turned around
enjoy smoking cannabis like never before
with an ice cold
freeze pipe the only problem maybe is
maybe your bong is not good it leaves
you with a scratchy throat and the
coughing
ditch the bomb
ditch the bong forever you've had years
of doing it now it's time to upgrade
to the best way to enjoy cannabis and
that is the ice cold
freeze pipe engineered to cool smoke by
over 300 degrees freeze pipes glass
pieces
will have you puffing bigger clouds and
zero chest or throat burn
the secret is they're freezable glycerin
chambers that come on every piece that i
mean it really is so cough less and
relax more with your new glass uh
coughless and relax more with your new
favorite glass piece
from freeze pipe remember these are
called
girls pieces like they'd say hey
is she a good piece or not yeah yeah i
remember that
i still talk like that
so do i
that's not gonna make any money oh yeah
okay we're gonna do one at the end of
the year all the inappropriate things
that we've said okay that's just the
show shop for the smoothest hit now
at the freezepipe.com use code omghi
for 10 off that's the freezepipe.com and
use omghi for 10 off
so that's the new guitar i've never seen
this one before oh this is beautiful uh
um yeah so so but but
if uh
here's things people don't do
they don't lock their [ __ ] doors
and they leave [ __ ] in their cars
if you don't want to get your car broken
into
do not leave your [ __ ] in the car even a
baby seat take the [ __ ] baby seat out
and put it in your trunk don't leave
your bag there don't leave your work
thing there don't leave your jacket in
the car don't leave anything in the car
there's people that just go around
looking in people's cars and if they see
a leather jacket anything they can take
or sell or do anything so you're making
yourself a target to be robbed because
in especially after the pandemic people
go around stealing packages
they got a ring camera but the ring
camera doesn't call the police yeah if
you're at work what are you going to do
hey this is a private residence
yeah don't do that
can you jack yourself
this is gil carrillo and i approve that
message put out by george so
we're creating victims yes we are there
anybody that goes out to the store after
dark
by yourself you're asking to get [ __ ]
jacked
i mean you go to the oh let me go to the
market and get go to go go in the
daytime
don't go out at night especially by
yourself especially if you're a woman or
uh um or anybody with a man with a kid
man it's dangerous out there it's not
just dangerous in los angeles it's
dangerous everywhere and don't make
yourself like a victim and lock your car
door all the time my uh
my wife my son lives within a mile of
where my house is
if my wife says she's going to the store
no no i'll drive over i'll go with you
exactly and so the first thing i ask is
son going with you and she said yeah oh
just what i'm going to say i'll go with
you
yeah and then he goes well somebody has
to go with somebody don't let anybody go
everything can wait during the day
there's much there's crime during the
day but you're not you're not
as susceptible walking to your car
pushing a bag of groceries and having
your you know you open your trunk and
your back's turned and then i've told
her time and time be just make sure
you're surrounded during the day
we're not together all day long
um
but crime is a
it's a big thing yeah it is i'd like to
get chris hanson on the show
because the crack to catch a predator
they run reruns that's that [ __ ] that
i mean it's awful man i mean it's awful
that
but
there's people on the computers that
pretend to be
they're every well well listen everybody
i mean
you can talk about tinder there's been
murders on tinder
you know craigslist there's been
craigslist the craigslist killer
but also
the dating sites they didn't have when
you and i were coming up and now
to open an account i mean they don't
verify they don't vet you can open a
tinder account which we should probably
do let me open a tinder account
and start
getting some viejas in here
can i okay here's what we're going to do
all right no i'm going to open a tinder
account all right
i already have one but i'm going to
pretend like
i'll open a tinder account and we're
going to start to see who i match with
and see if they can come on the show or
leave a voicemail and tell us what
they're looking for
in a man or woman i love you would you
be you i'm a target for put those two i
mean people who are
would it be you in the fake account or
would you be almost like catfishing
people just trying to get a match and
then be like oh hey this is actually
george come on the show
hey man
i'm already a catfish the way i look if
i tell them or not
um but i think i think let's do that all
right all right
because i'm making enough i'm just happy
to be here because there's a lot because
there's a lot of uh we probably can't
even show their names probably there's a
lot there's a lot of people that are
looking for
love and all the wrong looking for love
in all the wrong places shooting my
grandma on all the wrong faces
i jacked up on a towel my grandmother
used it she scratched her face
oh no hey congratulations i had to tell
them at work i had a cat
congratulations i already had another uh
successful golf tournament man
so i've been out of town i can't say
what i've been doing but i've been out
of town
and
i get i got back in
had to do a show last saturday
or whenever the saturday and then go
back and then fly and then go to the
party and then go to the tournament and
then go to the doctor and then fly back
then the flight was delayed
and i got in at uh two in the morning
and i had to be downstairs at seven
and i worked 16 hours at work 16 hours
the next day
okay so so
in this thing i'm working on
there was a scene where
i have the last line and i expose a
flashlight on something
and
it's difficult because you don't see
anything
and i could see the producers talking
about
really not liking what was going on
and i told the other actress
and we were in this old building in this
state that's not california
and i said to her
there are spirits in here
and she says there are
and i said yeah and i said but they're
not bad they're not bad spirits so
literally
10 minutes later
i did something in the scene that the
same people that were questioning
whether
it worked or not were applauding
and something came to me
that wasn't in me before i said their
spirits in here and that
section of what i did there will most
definitely be in the trailer of the
movie
and i didn't have anything
they were trying to cut the bait and and
and make it a shorter scene
and when i said their spirits in here
but they're not bad
something came to me that i didn't have
before
what made you say that were you feeling
yeah something in the air it's an old
building it should be a lot used to be
an att building and mobile wasn't with
you no more
you can't he can't stand for a long time
and and um
i got that thing came to me out of
nowhere
and that was at one o'clock in the
morning
after getting there after leaving my
hotel at 9 00 a.m where you have to do
something and it's you know
16 hours later and you have to pretend
like it's
just started you just started first of
all yeah and something came to me that i
didn't have
i didn't have it all and it came to me
so you know i'm into that whole oh yeah
spiritual thing but i i've seen on the
internet that
momo and uh
hefty i guess
are doing a paranormal
podcast
yeah they do a paranormal podcast um
in my bedroom this morning i got this i
sent it to the guys and they they
listen to what i think this says you
tell me you tell me what you think i
think they got i think they got hard on
them okay
yeah i'm gonna put it right here you
ready
okay
okay you ready ready that's terrible you
tell me what you think
i was in my house what do you think it
says what the [ __ ] is that what do you
think it says one more time
run it sounds like chingon oh okay
yeah it does oh yeah
that's a paranormal app
what
that's where else is in my bedroom see
the next one would have been me saying
i'm a [ __ ] i'm out of here that's what
there's a realtor saying so he lived
here for seven years how about that
dude i'm hearing i'm hearing it more and
more each time
okay that's that's
that's funky they're not all bad spirits
you just sprint out of there when that
happened
yeah aaron back there isn't it yeah it's
aaron that's everybody bear huh
so the tournament was a success yes and
then
here's the thing so
so many things you know everybody grows
up the way that they grow up however
however it is like i grew up
you know i didn't know my father ever
and i didn't live with my mother and my
grandmother was you know
worked during the day my grandfather was
a second
grandfather but was my
grandmother's second husband
and friends from mexico my original
grandfather
we didn't talk to
and then in
was it the early 70s
he was down
on like sepulveda and he
he chased my grandmother with a gun holy
[ __ ] we went over to this house and he
was there and he had remarried
and he chased my i remember my
grandmother they were literally running
through the screen door
and down supported down over there by
devonshire and he was [ __ ] chasing
her with a gun and i was probably like
seven
so you know i didn't have the best that
sticks with you yeah oh my god it's
awful man i've never seen my grandmother
run before
i started dribble basketball and try to
lift her leg with her dress not wearing
it because
that stays with you
i don't know which was worse her running
from the gun from her or me seeing her
[ __ ] panoche
what i i feel like general motors so
many things that come out of there i saw
my neighbor she had to be about 70 and
her husband had to be about 75.
she was chasing him down the street with
a hatchet oh my god what yeah she was
she wanted the good old days yeah she
was chasing him down the street with a
hatchet he got away that was frenchy
and her name was
oh it'll come but but also if you're
dating and you guys are already throwing
[ __ ] at each other don't get married no
that's a bad thing it's gonna get worse
if you you know people
you know people
don't say
the truth when the truth is when the
truth is the only answer if you know
women say
listen if you don't want to be here just
tell me and you know you don't want to
be there but you say no no i want to be
here but you but
because they're the women are taking the
chance that you're not man enough to
speak up for yourself
you know i learned when i was a kid i
was a teenager the manager of the band
that i was playing and she taught me
something i've never forgotten
palabras
that's elusive words
have no return i say it again slower for
the audience
it doesn't sound good in english let's
let's do it in it you say it in english
okay
what does it tell what it says
loose words
don't have return so you say that uh
loose words don't have return
yeah it's okay so that's right
it's just like ah all right but in
spanish
it sounds it's it's nasty so brilliant
i've never heard it before either that's
great and so if somebody says you know
what hey you know what we've been
married for three years let me tell you
something i've been faking orgasms your
dick ain't [ __ ]
and then an hour later i'm sorry i just
said that i was angry i didn't mean it
you can't take it back you can't take it
back it's there in the back of your mind
it'll always be there yeah yeah so i
learned don't say anything you don't
want
to haunt you back and you know people
say things to hurt other people or hurt
people
hurt people so so oh yeah you know hurt
people say things to hurt other people
but
i think the reason why there's a lot of
you know datelines and
oxygen shows and chris watts from you
know
frederick colorado who killed his wife
who was expecting and the kids because
he found some other woman that he worked
with and that woman was involved
even though that she wasn't charged i
know people i'm not sure if they know
the case she was involved and she
deleted all of the messages and all the
correspondence and deleted the pictures
and and the and the police said you know
if you delete that stuff it looks to us
like you're trying to to to hide things
and she says no you know i just he lied
to me and i was over it but no no she
was she she destroyed evidence yeah i
believe she did
she destroyed evidence that's why when i
saw john rene ramsey's dad there
they said gil you want to go to john
and i said no
i don't want i don't want to see him
was amanda knotts there too
no you know who's uh big titties
uh what the hell's her name uh eileen
warren okay
o.j simpson killed his wife and the dude
that he killed
alleged alleged alleged killed do you
know the joke that they uh ron goldman
ron goldberg
i shouldn't say this is true his sister
was there
she spoke arnelle yeah she spoke shirley
simpson
i don't know which one it was one of
them um oj's oj's dad
was uh i believe
of uh an alternative lifestyle
is that right yes
marvin gaye's father
was a cross-dresser
which
cross-dressing doesn't even come up
anymore yeah what's a cross-dresser now
because i wear things that are very
feminine
uh
[Laughter]
and she pulls out a a a little chicken
stick with [ __ ] on them
the same beef stick
the [ __ ] hair patrolman got back in
the 79 back in the summer i'm sick
you're gonna use that string as flops
all right let's get another beer okay
yeah let's grab some more there's one
over
there they uh
my buddy you said that
are we done by the way no we're not huh
just
just send me a picture the other day he
was on a flight a couple of weeks ago
and he said
he's got the window seat some other dude
has the aisle seat and some lady has a
seat in between she's she's wearing a
tight pair of these stretchy pants
she gets off she has to go to the
restroom she's rather large but she gets
up goes to the restroom so he gives him
a chance to stretch he gets back get by
his window seat he says the good thing i
said now first she showed me a picture
she gets back to sit down she's got
toilet paper hanging out of her ass
can't help but laugh let me see the
picture you got it on your phone uh you
can't help but laugh do you have it on
your phone
i don't want to say oh
and two i don't want to see it until you
find it
okay i'll show you when i find it
but what is the fascination with
women wearing yoga pants
or or they're not even you mean why do
women like leggings
i don't think listen man you see very
few
um you know what just because you can
throw a baseball doesn't mean you should
be a dodger
okay okay so there's a lot of women in
the airports that i see i only see
people in the airports but they should
not be wearing what they're wearing
uh what's the number to call in
818-533-18
okay ladies if you wear
lululemon
oh man that's a little bit
hold on i missed the contest
put that on there ah man hold it up on
the thing ah damn
yeah that's right that's your camera
right there that's a piece of toilet
paper hanging out of her leggings
or a fuse
[Laughter]
you like that who knows what's gonna
happen they would have had to have moved
me let's light this candle because i
wouldn't have been able to stop laughing
after you get me off the plane stop
laughing i would have been able to stop
[ __ ] scratching my [ __ ] self after
with the [ __ ] heaves the jeep
okay so so
um say that number again uh it's on
screen right now so it's a one eight
five three three eighteen forty three
vergas
so
awesome that's the name of my next
comedy special so so
if you wear leggings
but
i don't know
i really you can't really say i can't
really say what a person
body
how they're comfortable with their body
but let's just say that there's a lot of
people who are not
um
well you can't even say that either but
there's a lot of pants being worn by
women and and when you think that women
are self-conscious about their bodies
why would you wear
a sausage casing
to the airport
that's
a five pound sausage casing
with a ten pound body in there that's
what i'm saying
and that's what i think i'm not sure
what it is you know
i wear pants that are
that are baggy
but i would not consider wearing yoga
pants and seeing a little [ __ ] 31
flavor spoon right there in front
that little pink spoon that's what my
very baskin robbins little
baskin-robbins spawn
upside down backside not the scooper up
the thing down so it's about that long
and then it's got a little round
head
my dick looks like a keychain now when i
was in high school it was big
but somehow it got to be like a keychain
with time it looks like a [ __ ]
keychain my dick is the size of a
keychain now and not even a good
keychain when you get on i'm not gonna
ask you to prove it to me once you get
on the way now at bart's store right
there where they have their license
plates with people's names on them
a little a little [ __ ] editing like
that it used to be it used to be
i was quite proud of it and now
it's atrophied away
to appeal but also a skin tag
[Laughter]
when did it start when did it start
going downhill uh probably in my mid 50s
where
way too when i would wash it and not get
hard you know when you wash it when
you're young it gets hard because it's
still it's getting cleaned
and then i would put soap on it and wash
it and
it would reject the soap they didn't
want it it just says thanks
the soap wouldn't lather up
somehow the dick had had
had closed all the pores
and it said i'm not even going to lather
up because i'm not being used why clean
me
[Laughter]
if that's happened to you eight one
eight five three three 18. but also
explain to us why you wear the clothes
that you wear
and if you feel self-conscious or not or
does it matter to you or not
or body image or your body type and um
you know there's women that used to wear
baggy um
um
shirts to cover the fact that they were
well in doubt on time so
when i was at a golf tournament a long
long long time ago we had a girl that
was walking with us
that was that had
huge beautiful tetanus and she was a
little girl
a little she was already a woman not
girl she was a woman with what with a
bit blousy polo shirt but you could see
that she had a couple of like the
[ __ ] bumpers to a bel air the little
like that like a like a
cone shape i'm getting there now right
like this like this like this one right
here like a cone
and i looked at them all day and i was
like man and i told the guy walking with
us and said
man she's got some huge tits i mean wow
and he goes yes we've been together for
a year and a half
[Laughter]
i just think how big they'd be if you
were with her
is that awful or not oh that's that's
rough that yeah that's rough
yeah congrats brother
and he got all pissed off he started
walking the other side
so you're still here puto you're still
going to see me
but but yeah
i i i know in airports i see and also i
just saw a woman who
was actually very thin wearing those
pants that had camel toe
oh and i mean we're talking deep dish up
though like i like i like camel throwing
like like oh we just got the episode
it's not delivery
it's disjoining oh yeah
she had something so you know the the
threat the the whatever material is
right there
is like the heart of the watermelon or
the artichoke
then you get those cut you get those
yoga pants and then you put them
into a into a pitcher and you fill it
with water
and you leave it on top of your house
for two days and then you have sun tea
from her from her there you go
there you go you know
i was with chai
i was with my wife and you could put
sugar put split in there but i think
it's why not sweet enough on its own
take it straight
a few years ago or maybe that there's
some cockey maybe she uh you know you
don't know i'm weight yeah you don't
know you don't know that it could be you
know sweet and sour like a sour patch
kid
where you put in your mouth is sweet
sour and then you're like
all right what are we what are we doing
something extraordinary
my wife and i were at a wedding a few
years ago
and it was a beautiful wedding it was a
beautiful sunday we're in a big room the
people already have kids that were
everybody's there and there's a lady
wearing a sundress
we're inside and the sun is coming
through
she's wearing a white she was an
attractive lady a beautiful sundress
white lady white lady but you could see
as she moved oh i showed my wife
is that just me or is it she says oh my
god
you could see her string hanging out
you could see her string hanging out
from between her legs
and i just thought it was the cutest
thing i'd ever see
did you tell pearl that oh yeah i said
look at that
look at that [ __ ] isn't that cute
i don't know who she's more disgusted
with the lady or with me
but what's why is the string there
because so they can find it
so they can pull it back out i guess it
might get sucked up in yeah you don't
want to lose that
do butt plugs have a stringer then or
not no they have a flared base oh so it
it stops itself from going in there
i don't know i never stuck anything on
my have you as a detective you ever see
a dude with a light bulb in a school no
no never have anything nothing i've
never seen a guy with anything stuffed
up their ass but sometimes you know
doctors heard of them okay if you're if
you're an emergency room doctor or nurse
or urgent care nurse or doctor and
someone has come in with like a
matchbook box a matched car in their
cooler or the tv guide or whatever like
a remote control in their oil
the little apple one would work well i
could fit in my kudo i'm sure oh yeah i
haven't tried it but that's doable i i
haven't tried it but i i think i think
it would fit i did have a case and i
can't mention name because it's okay so
apple if you're out there how about
start making those remotes with a little
string on them so i can pull it out
[Laughter]
we had an officer involved shooting
where guys shot the guy the driver of
the car tried to get away tried to drag
dragged the deputy down so he got a
little herb but shot the guy we got him
in custody
and it was
drizzling outside it's an outdoor crime
scene
and i'm there with frank
and i'm processing the car i'm looking
at the car going through evidence
and we're not done yet
frank says hey why don't we just have
the car towed
inside you know and that way we could
come back and finish it so so that's
also a thing that that that uh they
still do that i'm
sure well if you go to the car
instead of examining it there you just
close it right seal it probably with the
with this with tape that say that so
nobody can get in there crime scene do
that oh we'd have it towed we don't seal
it right there toad toad and it said
you're not touched right at the police
yeah
so i told him i said frank i'm just
about done there's just a little bit of
[ __ ] inside
i don't mind staying out here you can go
something now let's let's do it on okay
so we towed in i said but
you're gonna finish it tomorrow
i wanted to finish it tonight you finish
it tomorrow friday yeah y'all finish
tomorrow
so go back there we interview
this female who was passed near the
vehicle
and she's sitting there telling us a
story about how
this guy picked up on her and hey you
want to go for a ride let's go for a
ride
and so all of a sudden the guy please
say you want to hit he had
uh he's going to hit some heroin
and she says oh man i think you shoot up
heroin yeah
i don't i don't really care no i don't
do that stuff
and he said no but i want you to oh he
says and i started getting scared
so i watched him hit and then he filled
it back up again and he gave it to me
and so i took a hit
he says really to me i didn't feel [ __ ]
but this guy was getting all he was you
know he's getting
all nervous so she did it yeah so she
did it and that she she was a prostitute
a sex worker too by the way that's a sex
worker that was called a sex worker sex
work is real work that that's that's the
so then all of a sudden he grabs her by
the head and he says get over here
and he wants a blow job
so she started blowing but she's not
really putting everything into it and
she's what's wrong he says hey and
they're not married no no
usually women aren't putting everything
into it they're mad
and so he says she's practicing what's
wrong he says hey listen
you want me to suck your dick i love
sucking a dick
she said but you can't just force my
head down on you to suck your dick i
mean you can but yeah so he says okay
just sit back watch and so he starts
jacking off in front of her
and then he gets this flashlight
is it me it's on me is it no the one
that i wanted sounds like i was looking
at he grabbed this flashlight
the one that he was going to do
something with before that i would have
processed the night before
wow and he grabs a flashlight
and she says
you better start sticking that thing up
your ass
because pretty soon you're gonna be able
to do [ __ ] you know it's gonna
you're and so he pulled it out of his
ass
and that was the flashlight he left
behind eventually because he got shot
you know we ended up in custody and we
got everything but frank know the model
of it was it like a plastic one or the
plastic one yeah but frank frank had
been looking for recommendations i said
hey
partner you're processing the car
tomorrow remember
not me so he had to finish it oh so let
me ask you let me ask you this so
because uh my uncles when i was growing
my uncles would have their cars and
pounding and we would get it and that'd
be an impala
can you look into a car
and kind of see what may have happened
in your mind
yeah you can't walk you know what i'm
saying you know what i'm saying like
like
you're you're a police officer so so
can you open the car door
and think
because of the way things are what might
have happened in there because
yeah you look at things that are
disturbed things that are broken
normally if there's a some kind of a
struggle inside maybe a seat back is
broken yeah you know maybe something's
broken up on the dash or up in the
of the uh headliner
here's one thing that people never talk
about because
you know um
netflix has a lot of new shows there's a
marilyn monroe documentary that's that's
really good uh that has interviews that
nobody has ever heard before and it all
but implicates uh allegedly because i
know the family
uh robert kennedy no in the murder of
marilyn monroe no
i'm going to say alleged because i know
the family i'm just saying that that the
net not me the netflix special yeah
all but implicates the kennedys yes okay
so so
of all of the crime evil genius the with
the guy that had the pizza bomber the
guy that had the thing around his neck
the one
sons of sam that they don't think the
son of sam was the guy that did it
there's some evidence in there but also
the one documentary that has never left
the trending or near the top is yours
the night stalker well i don't know i
never follow it's it's it's it's always
in the in the things that people are
watching
so even though it's been out a year and
a half
pretty much it's still
like people are still watching it and
finding it but also
tell me about the guy that got pulled
over that had the car that had women's
underwear in it and like pictures and
that guy you guys thought that you had
found the guy i do the roblox but he was
just a guy that was
that was another freak another freak but
not a murderer well he wasn't a murderer
not my murderer he wasn't your murderer
i don't know if he ever got anything
else whatever what did what did you guys
did you did you interrogate him yeah i
talked to him and what
what was he pulled over was he arrested
and taken in or he was arrested
and we took him in we set him up we had
a court order looked in the car
we looked and we had a search warrant
his car on a on a house yeah did
everything that and and that's where we
found all the
pictures the slice underwear everything
was at his house
and he was
no doubt
no doubt he was a con
he answered my questions as we were
going we had nothing
i mean he looked at me and he'd smile
you know why
hey we saw you we saw you ducking
down over there at the red onion and he
says i wasn't ducking i was tying my
shoes
wow
oh oh you drove around the parking lot
i got to remember that that's not in
that that's not in the documentary no
it's not this is all stuff with
because it didn't pertain they didn't
either so many avenues anything could
have gone through
they showed the documentary in the
investigation not every but i remember
you said
he's a he may be a killer he's not my
killer yeah he may he may be bad but
he's not mine he's not my yeah so so so
was that did that guy was he born in the
united states or was he was he from
another country or where no i believe he
was from here okay so so they live with
his mom
lived in his mom's residence
his mom okay and then he was uh
did did he have other people's lice
driver's license or his own no his own
and other people's underwear like
women's underwear they're all well i
don't think they were it's all because
if there were women's underwear they're
cutting the crotch
unless that's where you want to hang his
webbles you know they they shouldn't
yeah shouldn't have been like that and
then when you interview when you asked
them you were asking questions
pertaining to your case yes and
he clearly did didn't check out right
like he didn't check out he gave us
answers but the answers were all
answers that he could
there's no way was he lying to you guys
yes but he didn't need to lie because he
wasn't the guy he wasn't that guy
exactly he didn't need to lie
but he was lying to you guys yes okay
that's what tells me he was a con yeah
but not my khan yeah yep yeah he'd been
through he had been through
some kind of interrogation before
there's no doubt was he um
did you ever cross paths with him again
after that no
i was asked by the da's office
they had another case where he was
hanging around the school
and they said hey can we use your
information
on that case i said no
right unfortunately
it was
but you're letting it maybe a child
molester goal
and i'm saying yeah but i may be
opening up pandora's box with a murder
so we didn't let it out
have you ever seen laurel erickson since
yes i saw her when they made the
documentary and i've talked to her since
then laurel erickson was a reporter in
los angeles everybody and then
she
and her producer from nbc paul scolding
had flown to san francisco yes and they
were looking for the night stalker and
then the guy was watering the grass
and said was he an officer too no the
guy wanted her in the ground we may have
been from san francisco but
i i don't know and he said so what are
you guys here for that killer that is
writing things on the wall
and said that to the people from nbc and
then they were like uh
we didn't know anything about that and
then there's footage in the night soccer
uh
documentary of them asking you guys
and this guy's faces were like
well where the [ __ ] did you hear that
from
right
and they heard it from
the guy watering his grass
in san francisco there was stuff that
was leaked and you know you often
wondered where did it come from
and it had to come from somebody within
my department or somebody within lapd
and then dianne feinstein was the mayor
of san francisco oh yeah so dianne
feinstein senator is she's still a
senator did she retire she knows she's
still a senator
she's retired as a home office she's the
chairman of january oldest sin
oh she's going to so so and barbara
boxer i don't know nothing personal i
just wish she'd stop sucking free air so
the uh
that's a police way of telling somebody
to drop this yeah she's 88. it's crazy
does she pick that does
not mean i don't they shriveled up and
she's got like down to her thighs skin
tanks like my very guys she's got two of
them next to her
62 so so so
uh she was the mayor of san francisco
and then held a press conference
and released information that should
have not been released and that's why
the avia tennis shoes
were thrown into
the ocean in san francisco
right over there
that was the pair that they like golden
gate bridge right over the golden gate
bridge
yes that's when richard
he had started to use uh
estadia
but if those shoes were i mean we're
talking about memorabilia crime
memorabilia oh dude
if those shoes were around what do you
think they'd be worth people pay for
millions of dollars that'd be like the
hope diamond of crime paraphernalia and
what's the other one they have oh john
wayne gacy as well on uh netflix
yeah they do yeah they do
i was just told recently that
uh they're not gonna make a series they
were they were talking about making a
series following the documentary perhaps
and good news bad news good news is
the documentary was sold so well done
what are you gonna show in the series
follow up following up on that you know
so they're saying great job i still
think there's a lot of that's that's
what they're doing with the staircase i
don't know if you've seen that but they
took a little documentary and turned
that into an actual series too so so the
staircase have you watched the staircase
i've started watching the staircase it's
slow and labor what do you think what do
you think
the guy was bisexual for sure the the
alleged um
but you say that like it's a bad thing
no it's not a bad thing
hey you go out there and you're gonna if
you don't shoot it's like it's like
shooting a bullet versus shooting uh a
shotgun there you go with pellet you can
hit
a hundred things with a shotgun yeah if
you can hit one thing with a with a so
if you're bisexual you're a sawed-off
and if you're straight you're just a
handgun there you go no threw that
thought off
why shout yourself off to half of the
population why be yeah why be a handgun
when you can
shoot buckshot and hit 100 people i
remember my son coming up to me telling
me that one of my daughter's friends
had just had augmentation
breast augmentation and he said they
don't have better augmentation she
showed she showed me him she says it's
okay you're gay it would you know it's
you know you're with you're with your
sisters so i so showed him
i said son hurry up go back tell him
your dad's gay too
i wanted to see him
did that work for you no what did he say
what did he say
no he just started laughing he said dad
when eva longoria was on my first show
uh um
i was i played her wedding planner and
then valente came in and said if you
have if you want to get undressed in
front of me i'm gay
and i said rosie o'donnell
[Laughter]
so
okay yeah so that so i i think there's
still things in all of those cases yeah
the menendez brothers are in two
different prisons they'll never see each
other again
and then when we went to do the show
last saturday we passed by san quentin
and there's still a lot of
things over there you know charles
manson's gone but then you know
there's still
a lot a lot of of people who are
incarcerated and then
serial killers who are still out there
who haven't been caught yet
right i just talked at this last weekend
thing over in las vegas
guy's name is
oh [ __ ] why are you doing this to me
yeah i'm no good at names
you tell me i know that he was the guy
that discovered the dna on the golden
state killer
uh
paul holes oh thank you aaron from how
could i forget that i don't know i've
done it i want to say that we should go
over to aaron's apartment over there
there it is there's some driver's
licenses they're suspicious
we shot up a documentary with paul holes
about a year ago and i just saw him
saying whatever happened you know the
thing was going to go it was there he
says they sold it the fox fox got it and
then fox decided they didn't want to err
they would sell somebody out did get
distributed so and then i said okay well
so so be it
and paul holt said a lady asked me
saturday night
do you think there are any other serial
killers out there right now
and i said absolutely
you know they just haven't been caught
they haven't been
you know attended to
and
the next morning i get up
and i read
new york post just quoting paul holes of
saying
in his mind there are at least two
thousand
serial killers out there easy whoo good
guy i've heard like 30 to 50 as a number
three what makes a cereal how many how
many makes cereal three
oh yeah
three he says in his mind there's at
least
two thousand
now when you look out at two thousand
that's really not a bunch of them
compared to the population in the united
states
but there's still a significant amount
that they should be looking at
the problem is
it's hard to teach you know if you
listen to people talk
homicide investigators have big egos you
know they want to know everything is
this way and you know they want to be
what's right
when somebody tries to tell them there
may be something else going on they
don't want to listen to it they don't
hear it so it's difficult and i remember
at one point in time i brought up to my
captain then captain
uh hey i think there's something going
on over here and we ought to look into
this then i got invited to a meeting
and
i went to this meeting i went there and
they asked you to [ __ ] relax and they
yeah they asked me to [ __ ] relax they
just said i'm saying hey what's what's
going on and we talked about it and i
said okay so i took my information back
to my captain
and my captain just said at that time
well we got nothing solid let's don't
mention that
serial killer word around right now wow
so they didn't want to jump on they they
don't want to address it yeah because
that creates political problems no
you know in the news
everybody gets scared like there's no
real good incentive for them to want to
take on a bunch exactly you know what
it's crazy because we're already in may
and then we already went past the
anniversary show we didn't we never did
but talk to me about
about
nueva the sheriff in los angeles like he
was good alex was going to come on the
show
but then we didn't have him because uh
i've been gone or whatever the schedule
but
um
and you know this is just los angeles
but it's it's
why is he nationally known now yeah what
has he done
wrong i would say
is it right or wrong because he because
he wanted to come in here and when he
called us
and called uh me i probably shouldn't
yeah no it's not bad he said
i heard that your place is a place where
you can speak freely and i said
absolutely
so he wanted to come on because he
wanted to speak freely
um
why is the sheriff why is the position
of a sheriff now where the guy could be
known nationally how did how did that
happen
he just got recognized as sheriff of the
number one sheriff you know a sheriff of
the nation or something you know they
got some kind of award
but uh were you if if you did you know
politics is a strange is that an elected
it's not a it's not a sheriff is an
elected position oh it is yes you're
going to vote for the sheriff los
angeles county wow
and so
it doesn't matter if you're an lapd
jurisdiction it is the county
but lapd uh the the chief of police of
lapd is not an elected no that's an
appointed position
that's why
lapd a lot of people are against
chief moore
because he bows to the city city hall
not like chief gates
used to stand up to them used to tell
him whatever he felt like
and which was good they loved him i went
to a retirement party gates was already
gates just walked in the room and got a
standing ovation
they loved him why is why is that
because he supported his troops
and wouldn't let politicians push him
around okay that's why they loved him
now you got somebody like
alex villanueva who went in there
juan was not expected to win
went in there is the vast majority
underdog
but he got elected
and when he got elected he had one guy
helping him out driving around on his
own time
doing this who had been fired by the
previous sheriff
the sheriff had previously
fired him because there was
allegations of domestic dispute
and he had beat his girlfriend and broke
into her house
so
they did this
but also that sounds like
i mean
i mean that's that's you know that's all
bad [ __ ] but but people have people have
i mean it's so funny because one thing
can stay with you forever people have
people have things in relationships that
go sideways and sure people make
mistakes and you know you you can't i
don't think you can take somebody's life
and say one
whatever a party you're drinking
whatever i don't know what it is but but
anyways we're in a situation right now
where we hold people accountable for the
rest of their lives over something that
happens in one day
well what happened was
alex
rehired that guy that had been fired
and so now you have cruel who's
uh
against obviously against any kind of uh
domestic violence
and then you had a few other supervisors
and supporters but i don't think
anybody's for domestic violence no
nobody is yeah
but they jumped on the bandwagon you
hired this guy back after he'd been
fired by the county and they became made
it an issue about alex exactly and not
about the guy so they fought back and
forth over it went to court did this did
that finally the guy got fired but by
this time
alex and the board have already started
a major league confrontation whereas
before the board was kind of
ramrodding the sheriff right no more
so now he's standing up as a brand new
sheriff and he's standing up against
them the previous sheriff a lot of
deputies had tattoos from their monikers
you know marines get the anchor up there
yeah
navy army whatever they are well
deputies started getting mascots
tattooed
they had little devils from east l.a
initially
they had uh
the vikings from uh
let's say linwood station
they had pirates from firestone station
then they came up with the banditos from
east ellis all these things
and the new sheriff came in and said
i want all that [ __ ] gone
so at east l.a they had a nice
tile laden floor
dedicated to the
east l.a uh
they had a thing
and it was uh
a boot with a sheriff's helmet on it and
it said east la2
something uh
pantalones
that's a kick in the pants
that's what it's still for take it from
the riots nobody saw that outside of the
station
but the sheriff new sheriff came in said
i want that gone it's offensive
and so he changed all that nobody could
use it morale started going down he
started that was a vietnamese it no that
was mcdonald's before and mcdonald's a
friend of mine i love the guy but he
started making these changes they
started losing confidence in them
then people started getting
called in and fired
left and right
but civil service is funny because you
think it's wrong go to civil service
they may not agree with you and they let
you have your job back but what it shows
is you are doing something
positive
but it's not saying how many are getting
their job back so they weren't having
but even in a place where nobody saw it
it became an issue yes which it
shouldn't be an issue because it's just
it's in-house and the guys did not trust
him they did not like him so now
villanueva comes along
and he wins
he wins the election he takes over he's
fighting the board
now he says first thing hey all your
tattoos it's all back put that [ __ ] back
in there
everything's free again let's just yeah
but it doesn't make a bad it doesn't
make a bad person it's just like a
[ __ ] has a tattoo of whatever
exactly
you know alma mater or whatever but it
makes for fodder for the times or for
the board of supervisors
something just to pick up on them well
they've gone through this they fought
and then
what he did was
then he took on the board
when he says the people of venice beach
they're complaining about everything
well he looked up the law
and we all have jurisdictions within the
county of los angeles
and los angeles county though
he's in charge of the whole county
and there's something in the law you
can't quote me on it but it says
if they're not doing their job you as a
county leader
can take over and you can do it for them
so he started with venice beach
where they couldn't clean up the beast
the sidewalk down there
he went in there and he cleaned him out
yeah
the business people the residents they
loved him for doing that
but what did that do
to the supervisors to the city
councilman he just came out and said
they won't do it
the law gives me the authority i'm going
to do it they can talk all they want to
all their money i don't know where it's
gone but i'm moving in and i'm doing it
if you're if you have a business let's
say unfortunately you know because of
whatever's going on in our country after
the pandemic there's more homeless
people than they've ever been sure and
you don't know what they are some people
are just unfortunately you know didn't
have enough put away and then they end
up on the streets right but
if you're running a business
and they're urinating or defecating in
front of your business or sleeping in
front of your business it's going to
affect your business exactly but then if
you call people to move them away then
you look like you're
insensitive to the struggle of somebody
who's homeless but then again
you're
you're trying to to save your business
over the fact that maybe you have a
cubby hole a cup where you
where your door is somebody sleeps there
yeah and during the day they sit in
front of your
[ __ ] business
and
people they're not going to want to go
in there it's tragic it's it's a sad sad
reality
so he did he went in there and he
cleaned it up
and then he moved from there he went to
the va over
by the 405 over there and there were
people sleeping on the sidewalk in front
of the va they're not doing that anymore
no he got to do that you got the va
you got property they made those little
huts right the little yeah and they
moved them on the inside that's right so
they're on va property now
you know what that the a year six months
ago
my the we have the pre-party for the
golf tournament is over there and six
months ago
we drove by they were all outside the
gates and american flags and pow flags
and marine flags and everybody out there
and it's sad because you're like this is
how we treat our veterans and and then i
went there
just a couple when i don't know when
this is going to air monday or whatever
a week
and
it's
it's all gone and now they're on the
inside in these little kind of uh
where the rock lived and and be cool
that movie that this beget shorty sequel
there's almost like these little
these little huts where
where you go in there and there's
probably a bed and maybe a place to but
they're small and there's nobody outside
of the va anymore and everybody's happy
that was a big it's a big move and that
happened back considering politics
happened fast
then he went to
uh olvena street right there across the
street from alberta street
right around there around the freeway
they were taken over there that's right
he went in there to clean up palvetta
and he says i'm not done
so who in the public's eyes has he
pissed off
nobody
the
he hasn't pissed off anybody that
publicly pissed off board of supervisors
because he's saying essentially in your
face here we can get it done and here
are results
now where's that 25 or 52 whatever
millions of dollars they had for the
homeless what'd you do with it where is
it at what are you doing
and now they're having this
uh mark ridley thomas
he was the guy that made the
uh
he didn't make the appointment he
nominated
he's the one that got in the guy that's
supposed the attorney general
that is supposed to look over the
uh sheriff's department and villanueva
what happened to mark ridley thomas
he left the board of supervisors when
city council became indicted no oh
that's why he did so he's under
indictment how he was one of the board
of supervisors for law and he's the one
that
nominated margaret thomas has been in
politics in los angeles a long long time
sure
and they finally got after him yep and
with him gone
with gascon
i mean you've got
last at last count there were 23 cities
within los angeles county
that had sent letters of
lack no confidence vote or no confidence
and he's got now district attorneys from
other states
supporting
you have nobody likes guests going home
no nobody i haven't found normally when
everybody hates somebody you fight at
least one or two people yeah
nobody's come forward how did he get
elected
he had uh this guy soros
he had charlie beck who was the former
chief he endorsed rick caruso
endorsed him
and he had a lot of money coming in
caruso and charlie beck who's out of the
state now
have both come out publicly and said
we [ __ ] up yeah we we made a mistake
he wasn't the right man why did charlie
beck retire or why did he get moved away
he retired
i did a thing for charlie but i i liked
him i did too i did too when i see
charlie yeah it's a hug you know we're
we're his wife was a former deputy
so
but uh
what's the guy that went back to new
york he was from boston
oh kelly
uh robert kelly no that was the news guy
um
bratton bill bratton oh bratton bill
bratton
has come out
and endorsed rick russo
you know so he's come back made public
announcement charlie beck is caruso a
good guy or not he wants to run for
mayor of l.a yeah should we vote for him
i if i lived in l.a i think i would all
right all right well and uh on that note
i hate to be the time cop but we got to
wrap it up i know you got an event later
on tonight george
uh let's take a couple of calls though
we're gonna come in later on tonight a
couple voicemails what you got going
tonight george i have some things that
nbc
any word on the pilot by the way um fine
announcing uh we'll find out soon all
right
uh headphones on gentlemen if you want
to
listen to some vms
but i thought that was fun huh i think
it was fun to catch up oh yeah yes it
was great as always
i'm serious it was just good to see you
guys
i'll put a string in my oil next to that
next time i come in here
[Laughter]
all right
all right we'll wait for mr gill here
oh my god
okay all right everybody ready yeah
number one
hi george uh this is andres
um i'm actually related to
lee trevino on my mom's side believe it
or not he is my mom's third cousins but
we live in indiana
and i've never gotten a chance to meet
him and i've always looked up to him you
know what i mean i think people say that
the relative hey you got his golf swing
and i'm not the best golfer but i like
golfing but um
you know him and i'm just curious what
can you tell me about him about his
personality and stuff you know is he uh
funny guys he do bits is he humble is he
you know anything you can tell me about
him i would love just love to know
because i don't think i'll ever probably
in my lifetime get the chance to
actually meet him
so uh but yeah thanks george
that's a great question okay so lee
trevino is a six-time major champion
he's mexican-american he grew up in
dallas and moved to el paso
um he is in the world gulf hall of fame
people people talk about
lee elder who passed away he was an
african-american golfer he's the first
african-american golfer who played in
the masters but lee trovino was still
living and he played in the masters too
not to disparage anybody but a
mexican-american golfer who has done all
these things and who's still living
should be more revered than i think he
is currently revered and lee trevino
still plays i played him like he played
in my golf tournament this year he is an
incredible you know he's a loner like
like i am that's why i think we've known
each other 20 years and i think that's
why we probably get along so so well is
that almost the same person 20 years
apart but he's a great person he's a
great golfer he's been
beat jack nicholas and won two british
opens and beat everybody at that time
but um
uh i think he's about as he's maybe the
um
of all the people that i've met
in 20 years the person that i think is
maybe most like me and maybe my one of
my closest friends or considered family
would be leech orino so yeah a great
great guy that's a good one great yeah
yeah
all right next one up uh you guys
following the johnny depp amber heard
try it off we got a question about that
all right have you are you you ah a
little bit i've been following it check
it out
oh hey
what's up what's up
hey so yeah between the two of you is
that johnny depp
i don't think so which one [ __ ] is in
the bed
i don't even believe it was the dog
i think johnny depp was all also in [ __ ]
in the bed
elvis used to [ __ ] in the bed because
they would give them pills to to go do
the show and they were giving pills to
knock out but the pills to knock out
were stronger and in the night
and they would just
wrap them up you know
his friends would roll them over like
you do in home care
take the sheets
and they would say hey go throw them in
a landmark
i remember the landmark hotel because
you could believe that somebody's [ __ ]
in the bed in the landmark but not in
the in the international hilton where
elvis was oh
and then when i was at the hilton uh
like 15 years ago when i used to do
shows over there there was still the
housekeeper that was there
and that she said that mr elvis she
called him mr elvis would have cotton
balls with a little dab of blood on him
because he was allegedly using a
hypodermic needle but she would go and
clean his sweet up there in the imperial
palace uh imperial sweet up there in the
top of uh
the hilton and and she would not find
sheets stockadows those were in the
landmark but she would find cotton balls
with dabs of blood and couldn't figure
out what
that was from but you know that's from a
hypodermic needle sure
oh wait the ghost of elvis is coming to
me hey man let me tell you something man
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
would come out just [ __ ]
urine would come out of my butt i want a
man never to do that all right newton
never happened to wayne newton
and
uh
okay he's coming
up
a lot of times who do you think shot the
bed when johnny depp shed in the bed
kill any because of the
of the of the texture of the kaka if
amber heard
that [ __ ] wait a minute hang on and say
oh man one time priscilla shouldn't a
bit man i literally gotta have almond
joy honey
all right i'm back so so when a guy
shuts the bed you get a rorschach test
you know what that thing's like like a
butterfly there he is and then when when
a woman shuts the bed you get an almond
joy or like a mounds half of a mile once
interviewed a prostitute that said her
job was
[ __ ] on a man's chest
she was a dump on his chest i had a girl
i had a woman
i had a woman's [ __ ] on me
mine
different different animals different
animal
all right you guys want to do one more
yeah who's coming in bill burr coming up
who's coming in here
because bill no no no timing i just know
you got something going on
i was told 3 30 was was
but let's do it wait a minute
don't worry about everybody the colonel
said i can stay till four honey all
right
yeah okay here we go another how's my
elvis pretty good though pretty good
he's in the room
hey george this is daniella i'm calling
from oakland california um i actually
used to live in carmel that's my
hometown and i met you many years ago at
the tap room
um
you were awesome i've been a fan of
yours since um
early days of your stand up and the show
and um i just found this podcast and
totally love it it's great i think gil
is a perfect co-host
i like his
straight mandy you're funny and when he
laughs as loud as he laughs it makes you
just kind of laugh out loud yourself
it's hilarious um i love it when you get
killed laughing who is that anyways my
request
um you once did
i think you did one of prince's last
television appearances on your late show
and
you told a story in an interview i think
after he passed away about
a hat you had given him and i love the
story so if you get this and feel like
sharing the story about
your interaction with prince and the hat
i think it's a great story
i love the humor you guys have on the
podcast i love the realness of it
george i love some of the poignant
stories that you talk about at your you
know
um
your life experiences that aren't always
funny but they're real and uh i think it
speaks to all of us so anyway keep up
the good work guys still you're awesome
and um thanks bye is that what we're
doing here
do i have another beer let me have a
i'm not driving no i am but i won't
remember
could i have another
guy grant come on man get him
everybody's here again honey
i can't reach for it all right i'll grab
it all right come on so okay so hold it
right here is that true that that lady
says that is that true about the show i
don't know i'm not paying attention
grant
that's my third beer i never had was
that a real cut i never had a three beer
is that a real
that's aaron man using his other voice
the voice you used to lure via has
introduced his best priscilla presley
who shut the bed or no this is the the
prince hat story she was asking okay so
um
wow okay so so man this is crazy so so
on melrose across the street from the
improv there was a there was a place
that
made hats handmade and michelle who does
who does my wardrobe found this guy i
mean you guys never mean
and i mean handmade hats and i still
have a lot of hats
unfortunately
when i was in dc
in 2018 the the morning of my hbo
special on that saturday
his mom called me
and
said that amine was in a was in a car
accident and that he did not survive
and he came to my house and dropped off
hats he and cedric has a hat
all and this guy was a great [ __ ]
great guy man great guy
so mean made hats for me and i had them
still making hats handmade hats
so
um he passed in uh
august of 2018
but
i had him make a hat for prince not
knowing that prince was a jehovah
witness
i didn't think about anybody's religious
thing so so when prince did my show i
had everybody had a purple prince shirt
with the symbol in the chest and i mean
everybody was there you know it's very
exciting and he played amazing songs if
you want to see you can look on youtube
and look at lopez tonight and and see
that and then afterwards i went into
prince's dressing room myself
and there was a ballerina in there i
don't want to say her name maybe could
be she don't think she's
she knows nothing but i just don't like
to say people and then michael bearden
from the bandleader so i take this this
hat box in there from amine
and i was wearing purple shoes that i
got at fred siegel with savorski
crystals on them and then prince goes
man those shoes are flies or dope
something like that and then i said i'll
i'll have some made for you and he's
like you don't know my shoe size and i
said you know i find it out but then i
told him hey i made that i made this my
man made this hat for you
and and the white box was there
and he says you know george i'm a
jehovah witness man i can't accept gifts
you know
so i said oh okay so there the box was
there and then as we're talking he's
asking how arsenio is and then we're all
laughing and stuff and then he left to
go check the show and he came back and
had to do a song over because he didn't
like the way it sounded i mean that
that's how meticulous that prince was
like he held the audience while he went
to the trailer and saw his performance
and said i don't i'm not i think i can
do it better went back and did the song
again
and i think maybe did it twice oh wow
wow and uh so did anyone else ever do
that no nobody else nobody else ever did
that
so in the in the process of him coming
back now he says what's in there again i
said a hat that i had made for you
and he says uh
i said well at least look at it i said
you gotta at least look at it because
you know i hadn't made him look look at
him no no no
and later he goes it's a hat house and
open it up
so it's this white thing with a string
on it
he opens the hat and a purple feather
comes out like a long feather like this
and then looks at me like he looks at it
and then he looks at me and i said
yeah it's like that
and then he moves the white paper out
and it's this beautiful [ __ ] purple
hat with his purple feather and he takes
it out and he holds it up and he's like
this is for me
i said yeah but you know you can't
accept gifts
and he takes the you know when you when
you know hats and you hit the brim like
this like you know
a hat person always hits the brim of the
hat for some reason they and when he did
that i said i think i got him so he put
it on
it fit perfectly he's like it fits
perfectly i said of course i checked it
out and it just didn't have it's not off
the rack the guy made it
so he's got this purple hat
and he's wearing
this kind of prince thing you know and
then he puts it on and the girl says
like that looks
that looks sick you know and then uh he
looks at us and we're like man that [ __ ]
looks nice so he walks like george
jefferson yeah george jefferson walked
like yeah yeah up and back like three
times in the dressing room and i said
man it's too bad that you can't accept
gifts and he goes oh no i'm keeping this
he kept and he wore it out he wore it
out to the car he had a stutz bearcat he
had a stutz bearcat so imagine prince
was like 5-1 in a stutz bearcat that
they looked like he dropped a marble in
the car
you're looking for a marble look at that
big big-ass car and the gas pedal was
the symbol of prince
right the gas pedal remember when
chicanos used to have the baby foot
would be the gas guy
and then um
every hub on the rim like batman had the
bat that the the bat wings like they're
bad
and then his was his symbol on all the
rims and he gets in the car by himself
with the convertible down in a stutz
[ __ ] bearcat which is about as big as
this room and he's got the feather out
and he drives off i said you drove
yourself he goes jordan i drive
and he drives off and michael and i are
right there going there goes prince and
this that's [ __ ] bearcat with a
purple feather hanging out
and then michael beard goes driving the
wrong way
[Music]
trying to roll his ass but he drove
himself home back to back to bel air in
a stutz bearcat with a purple feather
hanging out
that's awesome what'd you guys tape
at uh uh at stage 29 the warner brothers
where they did the west wing oh really
yeah oh nice
all right one more let's do it
pretty good hug we did good for not
that's like a it's like
um oh my gosh hi
so this question is to both gill and
george is that how [ __ ] annoying you
were
if you were an actor
what kind of movie genre would you like
to be cast in and then why
and for george
if you were a detective
what unit would you like to be in i'll
be in the [ __ ] love unit
[Laughter]
where i would put a fake dick in my
pants
like imagine being a police uniform with
a [ __ ] dildo
with a crown a like like a fist like a
baby holding an apple the fake unit a
baby arm holding an apple remember they
just say that the guys
look like
awesome embarrassing so a little thing
right with a with a mansana right there
in my pants there you go and i would i
would be like uh excuse me can i speak
to you outside with a big apple a day
keeps the [ __ ] away you'd be like the
officer in a porno
officer porn
officer choncho okay go ahead and me it
doesn't matter what it is i i i'm
dramatic because i have heart i have
soul i can cry i would cry on command i
can cry when was the last time you cried
yesterday uh
no a couple over in vegas i got
teary-eyed but and the other part on
comedy because i love you on stage yeah
on stage
what made you
dad talk about your diet product no no
it was about talking about how
you know i did these things when i got
out and now i've been married
51 years and it's all it's not me it's
her you know and just
trying to tell people that it's
her you know it's just a little
emotional no no you have a grateful you
have a great great wife no she is she
she's still everything like
even though she teaches me like [ __ ] she
keeps everything together
no she knows she she's she's a good lady
um
is that tomorrow and tomorrow's mother's
day so there you go right here george
lopez podcast happy mother's day pearl
happy's mother's
happy mother's day happy mother's day
pearl to my mom who's out there
now
no
she might be
awesome um thanks everybody
yeah it's good seeing you again so what
did you say you would be what kind of
actor
i said either either or it doesn't
matter what would you be like like uh
name an actor like george clooney or uh
some
comedian spider-man comedic i'd be like
uh
who's the guy oh i said one more quick
uh peter falk
peter peter fox was here columbo and if
i was and if i was
a dramatic it would be just like my
favorite
show right now
and i've seen every rerun there is
and that would be blue bloods the guy
that uh
used to be magnum pi tom selleck tom
selleck
i love
what he portrays as chief police what
about if he stole your [ __ ] house
with a double reverse mortgage would you
still like it i don't need a double
reverse mortgage right now but i like
the way he treats his cops
and
i think tom selleck is a great person
i never met him one of the few people
i've never met but
some of those reverse mortgages are
you know because they give you money
while you're alive which i think is a
good idea for people who
don't have any family
so that it doesn't go into the state or
they they'll take your money you know so
when my grandmother passed away my
friend arnold worked at the bank that my
grandma went to
and you know i gave my grandmother all
this money and i would say grandma do
you have any money she said you know i
don't have any money george that's what
she was always saying so i'd give her
500 or a thousand or whatever and and
she [ __ ] kept it so in her account
was 38 000
and the government took it
he called me and said hey you know your
grandma has 38 000 in here and at that
time i never went to pull it out or
whatever i don't know how you get it but
then he asked i went to ask him about
hey what happened to my that money that
my grandmother had in there and he said
that the government took it
for 38 thousand dollars
i don't know how it works how those
reverse more somebody dies but reverse
mortgage i think
don't quote me
because you know
i love joe namath and i love jimmy
walker and they're doing the thing like
find out how you can win
you can you can get money you need for
fillings and catheters and
for dessert if you call this number now
you got joe namath who was broadway joe
and jimmy walker who said dynamite who
didn't want to say dynamite ever be
reminded of that he was yeah
and he does it so
and tom selleck does that so can you pay
a celebrity endorser enough money to
where
they compromise their integrity that i
don't know you know and he's an actor
and god bless him three beers i know he
he acts well enough to
and and the wife and i that's probably
you know one of our favorite shows and
we watch i watch we run i don't care i
don't i don't know how this one ends i
watch
but because as a character
he's serious he's the father people
listen to him
and he holds his children
to the same level as anybody else
um he doesn't come any slack nor would i
why would you watch blue bloods uh i've
seen do you watch blue bloods no i've
seen a couple of my family oh what are
you what shows are you watching
ozark have you seen ozark no hey man i
think you would like ozark yeah yeah
it's good i just started watching down
the staircase or something like that
staircase that guy's the guy that the
the staircase what about when the guy
hit up a pr uh a
male prostitute he went to court and he
goes how would you describe your
position um i'm a male escort an
entertainer and what do you do what does
that encompass and he's like um he wants
to say you know
and then he goes everything under the
sun
tell me where my next tour everything
under this yeah
with that and it's going to be me in my
suit with a string hanging out the back
all right thank you everybody for
listening thank you very much oh my god
hi it's great it's good to see you again
it's great to see uh
i am uh wearing the hat and glasses
because of my current uh thing i'm
working on nobody can see my hair we can
reveal more later and if you saw my
video you would see the the curtains
match the drapes
all right thanks nasty
put a little string behind chocolate
you